Republicans barely hold on to a deep red
district in Ohio
Alexander Ocasio Cortez has herself a
rough day and fallout continues from the
Alex Jones ban I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
Wow lots of things happening last night
was a big election in Ohio there's also
an election in Washington that turned
out to be too close for Republicans none
of this is great news for Republicans I
want to talk about what exactly is going
on in those elections but first let me
remind you that our national debt is
twenty one trillion dollars in counting
that is money we owe other countries or
at least Oh back to funds that we have
withdrawn money from it is greater than
the entire economic output of the United
States if your entire life savings is
tied to the US dollar you should be
asking yourself what's your plan for
inflation
if the stilts fall out from under the
economy higher wages can increase
minimum wage across the country import
prices are gonna skyrocket with trade
wars raw materials prices are increasing
with tariffs rising housing prices
that's certainly happening here in
California and the government solution
to a lot of this stuff very often is
printing more money which means
demeaning your assets degrading your
assets well the best way to protect your
hard-earned investments sometimes is to
hedge against inflation and uncertainty
with at least some diversification into
precious metals gold is a safe haven
against such uncertainty my savings plan
is diversified and yours should be as
well the company I trust with precious
metals purchases is Birch gold group and
right now thanks to a little-known IRS
tax law you can even move your IRA or
eligible 401k into an IRA backed by
physical gold and silver it is perfect
for people who want to protect
hard-earned retirement savings from any
future geopolitical uncertainty Birch
gold group has thousands of satisfied
customers countless five-star reviews at
A+ rating with the Better Business
Bureau
right now contact Birch gold to request
a free information kit on physical
precious metals it's a comprehensive 16
page kit showing how gold and silver can
protect your savings can legally move
your IRA 401k out of risky stocks and
bonds or into a precious metals IRA to
get that no-cost no-obligation kit go to
www.google.com slash bend they're the
people I trust for diversification into
precious metals ok so last night the
left was prepared for their big moment
in the Sun last night was gonna be the
moment when they finally won a deep
breath district now the last time they
won an actual red seat was when they won
the Alabama Senate seat because Roy
Moore had been the Republican nominee
and it turns out that he liked
frequenting the food court back in the
1970s to look for 14 year old girls
allegedly well he lost that election to
a Democrat but that was seen as largely
an outlier this Ohio election was seen
as more of an indicator as to how the
the elections of
are going to go this district is heavily
heavily heavily Republican this is a
very heavy Republican district when I
say it's a heavy Republican district I
mean that this district went for
President Trump by something like 11
points it means that if you look at the
counties that are surveyed in the in the
Ohio 12th district the vast majority of
them are are plus 15 overall if you look
at how this district has voted it voted
Republican in the last several election
cycles there was a Republican Congress
person who decided to resign and that's
why you had this special election
happening in Ohio's 12th district and
the Democrat in the county was the
Franklin County Recorder named Danny
O'Connor and the Republicans chose a
50-something veteran of state politics
again named Troy ball derson he barely
pulled out the election this thing was
narrow as all get-out it should have
been a Republican district plus 14 it is
14 percentage points more Republican
leaning than the nation as a whole
there's something like 114 republican
seats that are less Republican than this
particular district is none of this
looks good for Republicans even though
Troy ball derson picks up the seat and
wins the seat they're gonna have to do
this again in like three months because
the special election is only to fill out
the term that's currently happening the
the political geography in this district
is really interesting because there's a
lot of suburban districts and those
suburban districts both arson
dramatically underperformed he
overperformed actually in in district
lemon birth that he over performed in
some of the suburban districts
specifically because John Kasich came
out in endorsed him John Kasich is the
governor of Ohio I am NOT a John Kasich
fan as most people are aware but he did
not win the seat Roybal derson because
President Trump endorsed him he won this
seat because John Kasich endorsed him in
the last days of the seats these the
these statistics are pretty clear about
this nonetheless president Trump tweeted
out as long as I campaign and/or support
Senate and House candidates within
reason they will win I love the people
and they certainly seem to like the job
I'm doing if I find the time in between
China Iran the economy and much more
which I must we will have a giant red
wave the possibility of giant red wave
extraordinarily slight it is very very
unlikely that there is going to be a red
wave come November it could happen
theoretically but there are there were a
lot of indicators that were not
particularly good
Republicans across the country last
night in the third District of
Washington which is a likely Republican
district Democrat vote totals this in a
primary outpaced Republicans by fifty
point three percent to forty nine point
seven percent that is a contest that is
going to feature the GOP representative
Jaime Herrera Butler and Democrat
Carolyn long in November in the fifth
District which is run between
representative cathy McMorris Rogers
who's the fourth ranking Republican
woman in the House of Representative and
a Democrat named Lisa Brown the vote
totals showed that Republicans only led
by fifty point five percent to forty
seven point one percent that is not a
good vote total for Republicans in that
particular district and again in Ohio it
just did that that's not a result that
should be I think encouraging to a lot
of Republicans people are saying well
yeah the Republicans retain the seat
this is a R plus ten seats they retained
it by basically two thousand votes less
than two thousand votes
Paul Tarson one fifty point two percent
of the votes who Danny O'Connor is forty
nine point six percent of the vote and
the Green Party picked up eleven hundred
votes so this is this is not it's not
encouraging for Republicans it is not
and and anybody who is telling you
differently is whistling past the
graveyard and trying to suggest you
something that is simply not true
you have to look reality in the face you
have to look the statistics in the face
it is also worth noting that the polls
in this district were quite good there's
a lot of talk about the failures of
state polling in 2016 there were
failures of state polling in 2016
particularly in a lot of states where
there had only been one poll every
couple of months but the polling in this
district was spot on it basically showed
a dead heat the race was indeed a dead
heat so the polls were correct CNN's
John King he says that this was a big
deal last night that this was too close
to call he's correct about this
Republicans are taking solace in the
fact that this district ended up going
for the Republican but it is true that
this district never really should have
been on the table in the first place
during the Trump presidency the close in
suburbs in here have turned against this
president think that's why Alabama has a
Democratic senator that's why Democrats
did so well in Virginia I could go on
and I'm not including Pennsylvania
eighteen and Connor lamp so this
district is ruby-red Republican the fact
that it is so close is a big deal and
that is a hundred percent true okay what
John King is saying there is right and
it's why Republicans ought to be careful
with
they do in the upcoming months there's
this sense on the Republican side that
President Trump is untouchable that the
Republicans are untouchable the data
just do not bear this out listen I know
I'm not telling a lot of folks what they
want to hear but the reality is that
this is a district that went for Donald
Trump by nearly 10 points right it went
51.8%
to to Donald Trump I believe this
district actually the state of Ohio
total in 51.6% to Donald Trump the Ohio
12th district went to trump in a in a
landslide in the last in the last
presidential cycle and yet it did not go
in a landslide for for president Trump
last night Democrats have been routinely
outperforming in these special elections
by dramatic measures by dramatic
measures okay this is not a seat that
should have been competitive and there's
a lot of money those poured into this
district in support of ball derson the
Republicans did outspend the Democrats
and then they barely won the seat again
if you look at these these district
numbers they don't look good if even
half of the 68 Republicans who represent
a district less friendly than Ohio's
12th lose this November
Democrats retake the house with 11 seats
to spare if only 1 in 3 lose Democrats
stands in a net gain of 22 seats okay so
the none of this is particularly
encouraging for Republicans so when
President Trump says that this is just
evidence that Republicans are on the
upswing and everything is hunky-dory
that the evidence is just not there for
that meanwhile the Democrats continue
the radical wing of the Democratic Party
continues to gain in his ascendancy and
this is part of the problem with the
Democrats and this is why they could
actually blow this so the Democrats have
what you might term reverse Tea Party
problems there was a lot of talk in 2008
2010 2012 about Republicans nominating
unpalatable candidates because they were
the most anti-establishment candidates
the latest example of that was Roy Moore
in Alabama but you remember we nominated
Christine O'Donnell in Delaware instead
of Mike Castle and she ended up losing
that Senate seat and there are the
Republicans in Nevada they ran a
candidate in 2010 I believe who was
unpalatable and she ended up losing the
seats this is the sort of thing that can
happen when the base of the party starts
thinking less pragmatically and more
passionately you're seeing the Democrats
sort of do the same thing the reality is
that in this Ohio 12th district the
Democratic candidate was a longtime
Democratic politician with establishment
ties and they did better in that
district the same thing is true in
Pennsylvania but
Democratic base is embracing radicalism
full-scale indicated by the the amount
of conspiracy conspiracy Ilan sense
pressed by some of their more radical
members Alyssa Milano right the actress
she tweeted this out last night she
tweeted out you know what sucks because
of our unwillingness to pass policy that
protects our election integrity I
immediately think the Green Party votes
tonight our Russian meddling why else
would anyone cast a protest vote in Ohio
and there's so much at stake if you
actually think that the Democrat in Ohio
12 lost because of the Russians let me
suggest that you have now been
completely taken over by Trump
derangement syndrome so the Democrats
are having to fight an internal battle
between electing candidates who can
actually win general election seats and
electing candidates who are most likely
to vent their spleen and their ire at
the world and I'm not sure that's gonna
end well for them in 2020 because in
primaries in presidential primaries what
2016 shows is that passion actually
matters
well 2016 demonstrated is that when
you've got an angry base when you've got
an enraged base that base can make
serious trouble for you so Bernie
Sanders in the Democratic Party and
Donald Trump in the Republican Party it
seems likely to me that the Democrats in
2020 do not elect somebody to to run on
their ballot who is going to be a
moderate voice of reason
it seems more likely to me that they
elect somebody along the lines with
Bernie Sanders or in Alexandria Ocasio
cortes which is why most of the major
2020 candidates showed up at Netroots
this radical convention for the
democrats over the last week and a half
all the names that have been mentioned
are wildly out of the mainstream
Elizabeth Warren is out of the
mainstream Cory Booker is out of the
mainstream Kamala Harris is out of the
mainstream
certainly Alexandra Ocasio cortes and
Bernie Sanders are out of the mainstream
but those are the people that Democrats
seem like they want to push so if they
are practical then they will go and they
will find moderates to run in a lot of
these districts and in the presidential
seat in 2020 but if not then they are
going to they are going to end up I
think undercutting their own momentum
here which is the what Republicans are
counting on basically Republicans are
counting on President Trump to troll
Democrats into insanity and force them
to run candidates who are wildly wildly
radical and the American people cannot
stand that is the best hope that the
Republicans have here because the
Republicans are doing a piss-poor job of
actually representing their victories in
these particular
and in the in these particular election
cycles it is not good stuff and in just
a second I want to talk about the future
of the Democratic Party and this turned
toward radicalism but first let's talk a
little bit about what you're wearing
right now if you're at the office and
you're wearing a suit you probably got
it off the rack and it's probably ugly
the reason that you need to get a better
suit is because custom tailored suits
make you look like a million bucks we
don't have to spend a million bucks
instead you should head over to Indo
Chino it's the world's largest
made-to-measure menswear company they've
been featured in major publications
including GQ Forbes and Fast Company
that make suits and shirts made to your
exact measurements for a terrific fit
guys love the wide selection of high
quality fabrics the option to
personalize all the details including
your lapel lining and monogram here's
how it works you visit a showroom or you
shop online at endo Chino comm you pick
your fabric you choose your
customizations you submit your
measurements and then you wait for that
custom suit to arrive in just a few
weeks I've been to their showroom here
in Beverly Hills and it is just a lot of
fun it's really a blast you go in there
and you feel like James Bond you're
selecting your material and your lapels
and you can get things modeled it's it's
really awesome this week my listeners
can get any premium Indo Chino suit for
just 379 bucks and Indo Chino comm when
you enter Shapiro's at checkout that's
50% off the regular price from
made-to-measure premium suit again
shipping is free Indo Chino kaam promo
code Shapiro for any premium suit for
just 379 bucks plus free shipping it's a
great deal go check it out right now
Indo Chino calm and use a promo code
Shapiro at checkout ok so the best hope
for the Republicans considering this
wave of Democratic turnout which really
is pushed by the president's
unpopularity I understand among
Republicans President Trump is very
popular president Trump also has a bad
habit of pissing off the left to the
point that they actually want to go to
the polls and when you're the president
your job is to enervate the other side
your job is to take the wind out of
their sails president Trump is
constantly blowing winds into the sails
of the left by making statements on a
routine basis that just get them jazzed
up to throw fellow Republicans out of
offices they say I'm not sure that that
has a major impact on Trump's
re-election prospects but I do think it
has a serious impact on these
congressional races the corollary of
that is the Democrats because they are
so jazzed up could move radically to the
left and that means that their future is
Alexandra Ocasio Cortes now yesterday I
said that Alexandra Ocasio Cortez is not
the brightest bulb in the basket and I
stand by that statement
she is not in fact the brightest bulb in
the basket she was on pod save America
yesterday and she made a series of
ridiculous silly statements she again is
considered the future of the Democratic
Party because she's an intersectional
candidate she is she's a person of great
intersectional capacity to a woman and
she is his she's latina and that means
that she has valuable things to say even
if she is just saying random stuff all
the time that doesn't make any sense
well yesterday I'm positive America she
was asked a series of kiss ask questions
and she proceeded to immediately blow
them sky-high because she can't even
answer those questions properly by the
way you know there I've received a lot
of emails would I debate Alexander
Ocasio Cortes I would pay money to
Alexander Acacio cortezes campaign to
debate Alexander Ocasio Cortes I would
pay her money to come on the Sunday
special I would give money to her
campaign if it meant that she would
actually come on the Sunday special and
answer some serious questions from
somebody on the other side of the aisle
but there's a reason that she's only
existing in the safe space of POD save
America where they're just gonna ask her
questions like Alexandra where do you
get that lipstick Alexandra how do you
do your hair in the mornings Alexandra
can you talk to us about how Republicans
are mean and cruel yeah it's really
funny this morning she tweeted out
because there's a lot of blowback after
her various interviews she tweeted out a
bunch of a bunch of things about how she
how the reason people are coming after
her is because they're trying to
distract from this burgeoning Republican
scandal there's a Republican
representative who's now been arrested
for some sort of bank fraud I use a big
early backer of President Trump's and
she says the reason people are coming
after me is specifically because they're
trying to distract us whenever the right
is being particularly feisty towards me
the first thing I do is check to see
which bad news of theirs they're trying
to distract from lo and behold and then
shows representative Chris Collins in
New York from earliest congressional
backer was arrested by the FBI on
securities fraud related charges well
know the reason that we focused on
Alexander Ocasio Cortes is because the
media have fallen in love with the lady
who 117 thousand votes in a Democratic
primary in New York and we're all
supposed to believe that she's the wave
of the future that's why we're paying
attention also has a lot of fun to pay
attention to the dumb stuff she says
because if this is the future of the
Democratic Party the future is stupid
the future is just dumb so we're gonna
go through her comments in just one
second then we'll get to
all of the controversy surrounding this
Republican candidate this Republican
officeholder Chris Collins so here's
what she had to say - pod save America
she began by talking about what America
is not anymore now the Democratic Party
in order to win in 2020 and overall is
going to have to appeal to audiences
they may not like the Democratic Party
has made the argument that America is
moving in a different demographic
direction it's moving away from white
families it is moving away from families
altogether if you have to pick the
person who you are appealing to but if
you have one person who sort of sums up
the base of your party the Democrats
would say that person is probably a
minority woman who's either a single mom
or who doesn't have kids in it and has a
career right that isn't that as the
person the Democratic Party is looking
to appeal to right well whenever you
make a TV show in Hollywood you have to
think who isn't the member of the
audience who is most indicative of the
base for this particular show I think
that politicians do the same thing for
President Trump it was clearly blue
collar white males that may not work out
the way that he wants in 2020 for
Democrats however it seems to be that it
is minority females who this is Hillary
Clinton's entire base right minority
females who either are single moms or
who don't have kids and have a career
those are the people she's most
attempting to appeal to and then you
sort of backtrack to the more mainstream
audiences but those are the people
you're trying to get out in massive
numbers now the people that both sides
seem to be ignoring are white women in
the suburbs who vote an extraordinarily
high rate who are in fact mothers who do
care about safety and economic
prosperity george w bush in 2041 because
that was his target audience his target
audience was not white blue-collar males
in 2004 his target audience were they
were the so-called security moms right
those were the people that Bush went
after in 2004 both parties seem to have
neglected that Obama didn't neglect it
in 2008 he did neglect it in 2012 and
2016 both parties neglected that I'm
really bewildered as to why both parties
are neglecting mothers uh mothers who
are married who actually take care of
their kids and or have a job why is that
a group of people who you're trying to
ignore that group of people has mothers
who stay home has actually increased in
the American demographic dramatically
over the past ten years in the last
census that number stay-at-home moms
rose by 13% 13% more women are opting to
stay out of the workforce and take care
of their kids at home and that is still
a huge burgeoning percentage of the
population I don't understand why
both parties are ignoring it but
particularly the Democrats you would
think that would be the place they'd go
right Donald Trump is very off-putting
to college-educated women
he's very off-putting to suburban moms
why would they not be targeting those
folks but they send out people like
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez a 29 year old
former bartender who is single has no
kids and talks in disparaging terms
about soccer moms she sounds a lot like
Hillary Clinton back in 1992 talking
about how she's not a timing Wynette
woman she could have stayed home and
bake cookies and had tea parties but she
decided to pursue her career
that's what Alexandra Ocasio Cortez
sounds like right here when she is
talking about the supposed lack in the
middle class here's what she had to say
you know their heyday was in the 90s
when like you know kids had like fur
bees and like parents so you had like
soccer moms like two vans and stuff like
Furby is you bad yeah there's not
America anymore that's not America
anymore first of all like I don't know
like yeah like um soccer moms with like
two vans and a Furby and like this woman
is is clearly she's clearly the greatest
intellect the Democratic his party has
seen since probably Ted Sorensen maybe
maybe since maybe since JFK
I mean clearly this is this is this is a
person of great intellectual firepower
that now that the reality is again that
according to the census ten point six
million children under 15 and two-parent
homes were being raised by stay-at-home
moms and it's not that these moms don't
exist anymore it's that they're driving
SUVs rather than minivans
which brings us to the second stupid
point Ocasio Cortes made she was asked
specifically about the about the
breakdown in economics in the United
States what time across are missing and
she talked about the upper middle
classes clip 11 she talked about the
upper middle class which she says does
not exist anymore they were really kind
of connected most to an electorate when
they were fighting for these seats when
they got these seats when they're
campaigning most when we had more of an
American middle class and so I think
that politically disliked upper middle
class is probably more moderate but that
upper middle class doesn't exist anymore
okay she doesn't even know if the hell
she is talking about not only does the
upper middle class exist it is the
fastest growing segment of the American
population and has been for 30 years so
she just
making things up right now between 1979
and 2014 the upper middle class in the
United States increased by sixteen point
four percent as opposed to the poor in
the United States that number actually
decreased by 5 percent the upper middle
class constitute about twelve percent of
the population in 1979 it was close to
thirty percent as of 2014 so it's a
massive massive increase in the upper
middle class Steven Rhoads of the
nonpartisan Urban Institute says quote
any discussion of inequality that is
limited to the one percent misses a lot
of the picture because it ignores the
large inequality between the growing
upper middle class and the middle and
lower classes in nineteen eighty seven
percent of Americans lived in affluent
neighborhoods by 2012 that number was
16% the Pew Research Center found that
203 metropolitan areas have seen their
middle class shrink but in 172 of those
cities the shrinkage was in part due to
the growth in wealthier families so as
usual she is wrong shock of shocks it
turns out the Democratic Socialist
doesn't know if the hell she's talking
about but this is the face of the
Democratic Party and the the hurt didn't
stop there the failures didn't stop
there
I'm have to show you this clip or play
for you this clip in which she explains
how she's going to pay for things cuz it
really is astonishing but first let's
talk about your business you're not a
Democratic Socialist you have a business
to run and that means that you're
constantly looking to make your business
better and because you are looking to
make your business better you need to
talk to the folks over at LegalZoom okay
the folks over at Legal Zoom can provide
you all the legal services you need for
your startup your growing business and
they can also help you with a lot of
your personal legal work as well most
Americans don't have a will twenty years
ago that wasn't a shocking statement
because you needed a trustworthy
attorney but now LegalZoom has made it
easy to create your own which is why
more than a million people have used
Legal Zoom for their estate planning
needs it's national make a will month at
LegalZoom calm it is now your turn to
take control of your family and assets
with an estate plan it starts with a
will or a living trust if you don't know
which one is right for you no problem
Legal Zoom has a network of independent
attorneys who advise you on what's best
for you and your family and Legal Zoom
is into law firms you're not paying off
from rates make things a lot easier on
your family when you're gone check out
that Legal Zoom last well and living
trusts estate plan right now during
national make will month at
legalzoom.com plus they have all sorts
of other legal services for your
business go check them out right now for
special savings be sure to enter code
been in the referral box at checkout
that is promo code been for special
savings only at Legal Zoom calm where
life meets legal again promo code been
for special savings at Legal Zoom
they really are fantastic i've been
using LegalZoom for years long before
they're an advertiser on the program so
go check them out okay so Alexandra
Kasich does the the reason time
Republicans are talking about her is
because the Democrats have propped her
up as the supposed next wave of
brainiacs inside the Democratic Party
and not only that because it is good for
us to talk about her because I hope that
she's the face of the Democratic Party I
hope that they're their new face is the
Bernie Sanders Alexander Ocasio cortes
wing the worst thing that could happen
for Republicans is for them to run a
candidate like Joe Biden the worst thing
that could happen for Republicans is for
them to run somebody who can purport to
be moderate just long enough to become
presidents of the United States or
become senator or a congress person I'm
hoping the Democrats make a big boo-boo
here and they are so blasted out of
their mind by Trump's presidency that
they move to make Alexandra Ocasio
cortes their darling
okay so she was asked yesterday again on
POD save America a podcast run by the
Obama Bros right I mean it's a bunch of
Obama people who are who are running
that podcast and they love her because
secretly she represents their it'd and
she says all the dumb things they wish
they could say but then their their
super-ego kicks in and they say perhaps
I should not say this out loud because
it's a stupid thing she doesn't have any
brain to mouth filter when it comes to
this stuff so she was that specifically
about how she was going to pay for all
of her plans it did not go well you know
they say how are you gonna pay for it as
though they haven't used these same ways
to pay for unlimited wars to pay for
trillion dollar tax cuts and tax cut
extensions they use these mechanisms to
pay for these things all the time they
only want to know it just seems like
their pockets are only empty when we're
talking about education and investing in
human capital in the United States
education health care housing and
investing in the middle class all of a
sudden you know there's nothing left all
of a sudden the wealthiest nation in the
world has we're just totally scarce and
then we have complete scarcity when it
comes to the things that are most
important okay so I do love the fact and
the original question here was how do
you pay for things and her answer is
nobody pays for things Thank You
Alexandra Acacio cortez for that
brilliant exposition on the debt and
deficit in the united states by the way
woman she says things like the only
thing we invest in is
tax cuts and Wars that's all we invest
in this year we will spend four point
three trillion dollars the federal
government will spend four point three
trillion dollars this year what
percentage of that goes to the military
hey any guesses any guesses in the room
any guesses what percentage of that four
point three trillion dollars goes to the
American military establishment
including the vets how much it send you
you got a guess what percent okay senia
it says sixty goes to the military just
any guesses on what percentage of the
american federal budget goes to the
military jess thirty okay the answer is
16 percent of the federal budget goes to
the American military the remainder goes
to all of these supposed priorities that
we are supposedly ignoring according to
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez 62 percent of
the entire federal budget goes to
mandatory spending under Social Security
Medicare and Medicaid
the vast majority goes to social welfare
programs that Alexandra Ocasio Cortez
has we are spending too little money on
the fact is the amount of money that we
spend per capita in the United States on
social welfare programs is actually
almost on par with that of the European
countries and actually surpasses some of
the European countries and we are
spending a buttload of money on all
these priorities that she says we are
not spending money on it's just a lie
that we're spending it all on quote
unquote tax cuts first of all that's not
an expenditure that's me keeping my own
money and then when she says we're not
investing in the middle class understand
that when she says that we're supposed
to invest in the middle class what she
means is we're supposed to tax the
living hell out of everyone who makes
more than 30 grand in the United States
and then we'll pass it back to the
people at the lower end of the income
spectrum for investments in garbage
government programs that do not result
in higher productivity higher wages or
higher employment that is her actual
plan I would love I mean when people say
would you to bait her I would love to
debate her because I have one question
for her name an industry you would not
nationalize which ones should the
government not run and why can she name
any of them I have serious doubts she
says she wants to abolish the profit
motive
okay well then she's gonna have to
explain how she abolished is the profit
motive for that abolishing private
private industry or would she just
abolish it or why does the Democratic
Party thing that's a good idea
by the way when she says that we are you
know what we haven't worried about
spending in the past yes that's a
problem I'm old enough to remember one
Republicans thought it was a problem I
guess now we don't worry about that so
much because
president Trump's president so we're
supposed to ignore the fact there's a 21
trillion dollar national debt but that
sucker is gonna come do Social Security
will be bankrupt in the next decade
Medicare will be bankrupt a decade after
that these programs are not going to be
around or if they are around they're
going to require massive cuts or massive
taxes and even so what I love most I
think what I love most is that she says
that you know we're we've never had to
worry about we're spending this sort of
money before the kind of money that
she's proposing spending is so insane
that it makes what we have spent before
absolutely obsolete according to the
Mercatus Center a libertarian-leaning
Center at George Mason University they
estimated that Bernie Sanders is
Medicare for all plan we talked about
this last week would cost the government
32 trillion dollars over the next decade
but we can actually do a budget exercise
using nonpartisan and even left-leaning
groups
voxcom you know a left-wing source they
talk about what exactly we would have to
pay for a single-payer health care at
jobs guarantee and free College what
exactly what it cost well it turns out
that it would cost according to the Tax
Policy Center according to the Tax
Policy Center it would cost legitimately
trillions and trillions and trillions
and trillions of dollars forty two point
five trillion dollars in new proposals
over to the next decade on top of the
twelve point four trillion dollar
baseline deficit to put this in
perspective according to voxcom
Washington is currently projected to
collect forty four trillion dollars in
taxes in revenues as they call it over
the next decade
okay the Republican tax cut the fiscal
Armageddon will cost less than two
trillion dollars over the next decade so
we're spending 44 trillion but Alexandra
Ocasio Cortez has the real problem is
those tax cuts that quote unquote cost
two trillion dollars what is the
thirty-year projected tab for these
programs that they're talking about the
thirty-year projected tab is I kid you
not
218 trillion dollars on top of an 84
trillion dollar baseline deficit driven
by Social Security Medicare and the
resulting internet costs federal
spending which is typically between 18
and 22 percent of GDP in the United
States would soar past 40 percent of GDP
on its way to 50 percent of GDP within
three decades and she says oh we've
never had to worry about spending before
well turns out if you quad
drupal the spending you might have to
worry about it a little bit more he got
a you got a ten thousand dollar credit
card debt and then you decide to rack up
another forty thousand dollars of credit
card debt maybe you ought to think about
whether the original that was a good
idea but quadrupling it is an even
better idea
hey we'd be at sixty percent of GDP by
that point okay within three decades
state and local government spending
would push the total cost of government
according to Sanders in Ocasio Cortez
all the way to sixty percent of GDP
sixty percent of every buck made in the
United States would be spent by the
federal government exceeding the current
spending level of every single European
country and this is their big idea this
is what they think is gonna win them
elections good luck good luck and again
this is vox.com we talked a little bit
more about the radicalism of the
democrats which is being obscured by the
fact that we have to talk about the
constant stream of scandals and stupid
inside the republican party if we talk
about this every day it would be very
difficult for Democrats to win we don't
talk about it any day except on this
show because we're too distracted with
all the rest of the nonsense first I
want to talk about your sleeve quality
so I am NOT famous for being good at
sleep but one of the things that makes
me better at sleep is my helix sleep
mattress working with the world's
leading sleep experts helix sleep
developed the mattress that is
customized to your specific height
weight and sleep preferences so you can
have the best sleep of your life in an
unbeatable price here's how it works you
go to helix sleep calm you fill out
their two minute sleep quiz and they
will design your custom mattress they
can even customize each side for you and
a partner in 2018
helix sleep has taken customized sleep
to the next level but the helix pillow
these are only pillows they're fully
adjustable you can achieve perfect
comfort regardless of sleep position or
body type helix sleep has thousands of
five-star reviews plus you get a hundred
nights to try them out I was so
impressed by helix sleep that I told my
sister about it when she got married she
asked for that as her wedding gift we
got a reg helix sleep mattress and it is
just awesome she loves it we love our
own helix sleep mattress it comes in the
mail ya unwrap it inflates right in
front of you you pop it on the bed frame
you're good to go it's really convenient
it's really easy and it's personalized
to you helix sleep comm slash pen go
there right now you'll get up to 125
bucks toward your mattress order again
that's helix sleep comm slash pen for up
to 125 bucks off your mattress or to go
check it out right now
helix sleep calm so that's been is a
luxury mattress at a non luxury price
helix sleep comm slash Ben go check it
out okay so I want to talk a little bit
more about the cost of the radicalism of
the
Democrats and yet white Republicans
can't take advantage of that but first
you're gonna have to go over to Daley
wire.com $9.99 a month gets you the
subscription
it helps us here it really does people
say how can we support the show how can
we support the site go subscribe that's
how you can help support us seriously
and make sure that we are able to employ
the dozens of people who we have worked
on the show every single day to whom I
am deeply grateful despite my caddy
remarks about them on a constant basis
so you can go check that out for $9.99 a
month also for 99 dollars a year you got
this the left is yours hot or cold
tumblr is cheaper than the monthly
subscription also you get an awesome
giveaway gift the leftist chairs hot or
cold tumblr so go check that out as well
also please subscribe youtube itunes we
have a brand new sunday special you can
only get if you subscribe over in itunes
or youtube our sunday special this week
features the entrepreneurial guru Tai
Lopez it was a lot of fun
hey here's here's a little bit of a
preview alright it's Tyler Pez here I'm
gonna be on the bench purush show this
Sunday he got me to talk about stuff
that nobody's been able to get me to
talk about a little bit of religion a
little bit of politics but we're gonna
talk about entrepreneurial ISM Mentors
and what I learned from my hundred year
old grandma okay so it's pretty great so
go check that out this Sunday and make
sure you subscribe be getting YouTube in
iTunes we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
to conclude our analysis of the
stupidity of the program now being
pressed by Democrats as the future this
democratic socialist program according
to voxcom again voxcom
a wild left-wing source they say that
single payers is not just involved a
straightforward shift from private
payment to taxes so one of the great
lies that's being told is well if we
spend 32 trillion dollars over the next
10 years we'll save money on health care
huh okay
why because we'll take all of our
private spending it'll just be
government spending we'll just tax you
and we'll spend it that's not how it
works you idiots
you idiots people buy supplemental
insurance even if they are on Medicare
because Medicare coverage kind of sucks
okay here's the dirty truth about
Medicare the health outcomes for people
who have Medicare is not dramatically
better than the health outcomes for
people who do not have insurance at all
okay seriously there been studies that
have been done on this and what they
suggest is that Medicare health outcomes
are not always better than not having
Medicare why because doctors don't
accept Medicare in many cases sometimes
emergency medicine is better sometimes
paying cash out of pocket is better
people buy supplemental insurance
because Medicare does not do the job it
makes people feel comfortable but it is
not always the best system not only that
Medicare is based on a certain level of
collective bargaining with the doctors
hey if you had everybody in ensconced in
the single-payer system the demand for
services goes up Medicare would have to
collectively bargain it differently and
you would actually have an increase in
prices or a shortage of doctors or both
you have to basically you always have a
choice in these nationalized health care
systems you don't have to abolish the
private sector or you have to allow the
private sector to up charge and that
this was a serious battle in Canada
there was an attempt to actually abolish
private practice in Canada because there
were too many people who are opting out
of the system and paying private doctors
and they had a shortage of doctors who
they wanted to leverage into the public
system here's what box says single-payer
would not fix Washington's current
unsustainable health spending
Medicare's existing six trillion dollar
cash shortfall over the next decade
which soars to 40 trillion over 30 years
would not be reduced because Medicare is
already a price controlled single-payer
system have merely become more generous
under Medicare for all second
single-payer proponents claim that
thirty two trillion dollars in
single-payer costs should be considered
differently from other expenditures
since money spent privately on health
insurance and other health care costs
would now be spent by the government so
you just shift the money from the
private
what sector this is false the four
trillion dollars saved by state and
local governments on programs like
Medicare and chip over 10 years and the
22 trillion dollars saved by families
and businesses on premiums and
out-of-pocket expenses cannot be
converted into a 26 trillion single
payer tax without serious economic and
redistribute of side effects designing a
politically acceptable 26 trillion
dollar tax hikes is nearly impossible
Medicaid recipients who currently pay no
health insurance premiums would not
receive any insurance premium windfall
to help for their steep new taxes so
actually this is completely unrealistic
even according to folks on the left so
it's going to cost a damn fortune and
yet Republicans aren't talking about
this stuff what are we talking about
today what we're talking about scandals
involving Chris Collins federal
prosecutors in New York on Wednesday
charge New York Republican
representative Chris Collins his son and
another man with 13 counts of securities
fraud it's perfect timing I remember
back in 2006 Republicans look like they
might do okay in the midterms and then
they just got blown out because the Mark
Foley scandal a situation in which a gay
Republican congressman was was hitting
on the interns basically in the
congressional pages that worked out
horribly for Republicans they lost what
60 seats in 2006 so you could see
something similar happened if
Republicans are perceived as corrupt it
depresses the turnout Collins is the
first sitting member of Congress to
endorse President Trump he surrendered
Wednesday morning at his Attorney's
office in Manhattan according to the FBI
according to prosecutors he actually
used insider trading to trade on the
stock of a pharmaceutical company innate
immune of therapeutics limited of which
Collins is a board member to avoid more
than seven hundred sixty eight thousand
dollars in losses that would have
incurred if they had traded the stock
after a certain drug trial results
became public so this guy could easily
go to jail or we're talking about
President Trump's latest tweets about
Robert Muller or we're talking about
LeBron James imagine if Republicans
actually talked incessantly about the
fact that Democrats have crazy spending
plans want to nationalize nearly
everything and are propping up people
like Alexandra Ocasio Cortez and keith
Ellison as the leaders of the party
imagine if that word the program as
opposed to these constant day-to-day
battles over the fake news imagine if if
Democrats were depressed enough that
they weren't able to actually go out to
vote because it turns out that their own
candidates are radical nutjobs
instead we have to discuss the headline
of the day and this is this
the real problem it's a serious problem
that our our lodestar in politics the
the black hole around all which all of
politics revolves are these high-level
twitter battles between the President of
the United States and whomever is in his
grille that day it's just not worthwhile
it is not worthwhile hittin Democrats
hard is easy to do and fun it can be
enjoyable as well as worthwhile but you
actually have to hit them on their
agenda and the foolish things they are
embracing insane
you really think the cory booker is a
tough target you really think alexandra
Ocasio cortez is a tough target i'll say
robert muller is a lot tougher target
than any of those folks and we're
spending all of our effort right now on
defending the myriad salinas's that are
emanating from republicans who feel the
necessity to a swage president Trump's
ego if President Trump wants a
Republican Congress how about this less
on Trump more on Democrats 2016 one well
for Republicans because it was more of a
referendum on Hillary Clinton than it
was on Donald Trump it was not a giant
upswing for Donald Trump it was people
didn't like Hillary Clinton until
Democrats didn't show up to vote for her
make every election a referendum on
Democrats that's how you win elections
the way you want the we won the 2004
election Republicans because it was a
referendum on John Kerry not a
referendum on george w bush was a
referendum on john kerry's pusillanimous
behavior over the course of his career
Republicans won in 2010 and 2012 and
2014 in Congress because it was a
referendum on Barack Obama whomever an
election becomes a referendum on loses
right now all these elections are a
referendum on Trump that's not going to
be good for the Republican Party it just
isn't okay in just a second I want to
talk in a little bit about the alex
jones fallout so democrats continue to
claim people on the left continue to
claim that the ban on alex jones is
actually a good thing that twitter
mobbing and social media mobbing is
actually a positive useful thing you
know twitter itself did something i
thought was actually good yesterday they
came out they're the only social media
company that did not ban all of Alex
Jones's content all of the other ones
basically coordinated to take down Jones
now as I've said I think that Alex Jones
is a giant pile of human excrement I
think he's a bad guy who says bad things
he says conspiratorial idiotic things
that are nasty and evil and he says
terrible things about families of
shootings and is just he's just he's
that garbage he but if you're going to
ban him from social services yeah from
social media you actually have to come
up with a rationale the ban I mean it
can't just be we don't like what he says
so Jack Dorsey who's the head of Twitter
he tweeted this out yes sir he's getting
all sorts of flack for but he's correct
he says we didn't suspend Alex Jones or
Infowars yesterday we know that's hard
for many but the reason is simple he
hasn't violated our rules well in force
if he does and will continue to promote
a healthy conversational environment by
insuring tweets aren't artificially
amplified and continued along these
lines
he says truth is we've been terrible at
explaining our decisions in the past
we're fixing that I'm gonna hold John's
to the same standard we hold to every
account not taking one-off actions to
make us feel good in the short term and
adding fuel to new conspiracy theories
all of this is perfectly appropriate
jack has this right okay the fact that
this is the only time you may hear me
say this I think Jack Dorsey has this
exactly right Twitter has it exactly
right right now we in the country are
worried so deeply about incivility that
there are a lot of us who just want to
ban the opposing view in order so that
we can get to civility the truth is that
that actually is a form of incivility
there are two polls when it comes to
civility and both of them are bad one is
banned everything I don't like for the
sake of civility and the other is yell
at each other for the sake of social
media mobbing for the sake of civility
and then on the other side you have shut
down all of the all the things I don't
like for the sake of civility right so
we'll yell at each other for the sake of
stability because you're not civil
enough so I'll yell at you for the sake
of civility and then there is we want to
ban you for the sake of civility the
answer is that we should be somewhere in
between which is rational discussion in
which we can dismiss fools like Alex
Jones as part of the conversation right
he and be part of the conversation long
enough for us to dismiss the stupidities
that he spouts on a daily basis but that
involves actually not banning people and
yet the prevailing opinion on the left
is that some online mobs are good
there's a piece by Amanda Hess over at
the New York Times that is just an awful
stupid piece over the New York Times
suggesting and social media mobs on the
left are good social media mobs on the
right or bad so here's what she writes
she says isn't it amazing what people
can do when they put their minds
together on a Monday in July a casting
announcement blitz the Hollywood press
Scarlett Johansson would star in a
forthcoming drama as Dante techs kill a
real-life 1970s underworld kingpin who
according to the deadline
flourished in a male-dominated business
of massage parlors and
prostitution by essentially taking on
the physical identity of a man within
hours those suspicions were brewing
online commentators noted that Gil
appeared to live as what we would now
call a transgendered and man
not a woman cross-dressing to get ahead
by the time Daniella green Bama
conservative writer at Business Insider
defended Johansson for just doing her
job the wrath she met was so forceful
that her editor scrubbed the column from
the web twelve days into the controversy
Johansson announced her decision to
respectfully withdraw from the project
and then this this columnist goes on to
talk about Hollywood MA bangs the mark
Duplass situation we talked about a
couple of weeks ago the director who's
basically mobbed into apologizing for
saying that folks might want to follow
me on Twitter the mobbing of James Gunn
and what this columnist for The New York
Times says is that these mobs are not
all alike
but the mob that targeted Scarlett
Johansson and Daniela Greenbaum is a
good mob the mob that targeted James
Gunn is a bad mob how do we know which
mobs are good and which one is bad and
which ones are bad by the level of
sincerity by the level of sincerity
that's how you can tell because if
people are sincerely upset by a
transgender man being played by Scarlett
Johansson then we know that they are a
good mob and if they are not sincere
about James Gunn they're just going
after James going to go after James gun
then they are an insincere mob and we
know that sincere mobs are better than
insincere mobs now my question is what
the hell would make us answer my better
than an insincere mob I'm sure there
were legitimate lynch mobs that were
that were sincere in their absolute
hatred of black folks they were evil
it's sincerity does not confer any sort
of moral privilege upon you sincerity
means nothing but really this is just an
excuse for suggesting that mobs of the
left are good and mobs of the right are
really really really bad
the truth is mobs all the way around are
not good and the mobbing of people who I
find execrable I think is is simply not
worthwhile and not only not worthwhile
it's not it's unreasonable and actually
destroys civility yeah the idiots like
Jeet here who I guess writes for The
Atlantic tweet this ad about Barry Weiss
New York Times columnist she was being
sent to Australia to do some writing
she says the prospect of Barry Weiss in
Australia is frankly terrifying
terrifying if you feel that that is a
terrifying thing then you are part of
the problem and someone pays this
to write words it's just it's an
incredible incredible thing if you
actually want a civil America where we
can have conversations with each other
you're going to need to accept that
there will be different points of view
and that they shouldn't be so
medium up okay time for a couple of
things that I like and then a couple of
things that I hate so things that I like
today you know every so often I'm just
in a bad place and yesterday for
whatever reason I was in kind of a
grumpy mood I think it's because I've
been on this diet and diets are terrible
but that that said one of the things
that put me back in a good mood was
listening to some Mozart this is one of
my favorite pieces of Mozart it's the
flute and harp concerto in C and it's
just a superlative piece of work of
course because Mozart wasn't one of the
great geniuses in human history
paralleled only I have been told by
jay-z
so here is here is Wolfgang Amadeus
Mozart the flute and harp concerto in C
[Music]
so when people say I'm an elitist about
music yes yes because this is good music
and there's a lot of very very bad
stupid music this is good music okay if
this doesn't speak to your soul in a
different way than the random pop music
that you're smashing your head and your
steering wheel over then I would suggest
that you that you think a little bit
more deeply about the kind of music you
listen to listen at some point I should
do sort of an introduction to classical
music course not really based on music
theory because I'm not an expert in that
but at least introducing people to kind
of user friendly classical music because
most people think classical music who
goes on so long and it's so boring why
can't we just have a three-bar chorus
that we sing over and over for eight but
it is why can't we do that okay the fact
is that yeah there's a bunch of people
who think Led Zeppelin's Stairway to
Heaven is a great piece of music it has
a catchy opener okay leads that piece is
it how long is that song eight minutes
it's an eight minute song okay shut your
head okay eight minutes for stairway to
heaven you could get that or you get the
first movement of Beethoven's fifth
symphony and there is not a comparison
fine call me an elitist I don't care
okay other things that I like today
Jason Riley has a great piece over at
the Wall Street Journal Jason Riley is a
black columnist for The Wall Street
Journal which means that the left hands
attack him as racist for writing this
he says liberal racism is not a horse of
a different color
he says bigotry is bigotry whether
systemic as at Harvard or idiosyncratic
like Sarah Zhong's Twitter feed it says
to paraphrase a well-known political
figure miss John could stand in the
middle of Fifth Avenue and shoot a white
person without losing the support of
liberals it's a safe bet she was tapped
by the times because of these racial
prejudices not despite them editorial
board members are hired to help
formulate and Express the official
position of a newspaper
miss Jang is being hired to speak for
The Times and they like where she's
coming from the grey lady attacks
president Trump is a racist and a sexist
on a near daily basis and columnist like
Charles blow write about little else so
it is hypocritical for the paper to hire
and defend a new editorial board member
who's made no secret of her own biases
of course it is but that's considered
beside the point by people who share ms
John's worldview he goes on he talks
about this particular double standard
there's a great piece also by raha right
hand salaam over at the atlantic about
this tendency of people on the left
particularly white folks on the left to
try and
enter into the elitist stratosphere by
suggesting that racism by certain people
there's sort of paternalistic racism
attitude that that's okay racism by
certain people is okay because they've
been historically victimized this gains
you access to the highest levels of
leftist thought it's a great piece you
should go check it out by Jason Riley
over at The Wall Street Journal okay
time for a couple of things that I hate
okay so Jason Rance has a piece over at
Daily wire exposing this ridiculous
attack so here is what he writes is when
Diane from Connecticut saw that the 80s
sitcom elf earned a potential reboot she
was ecstatic not because she was
personally a fan of the show necessarily
but because it brought up memories of
her son Timothy who passed when he was
just 24 little did she know that her
sweet tweet would earn her a vicious
callous attack from seattle-based
jeopardy champ Ken Jennings so she
tweeted out Alf was my son's favorite
character he had so many elf puppets
when he died we buried them together and
had an alpha engraved into his headstone
then my daughter got an elf tattoo in
honor of her brother no matter what elf
is special to our family and this was
apparently the response from Ken
Jennings this awful mega grandma is my
favorite person on Twitter yes clearly
she's awful because she liked Alf if
only she'd liked transparent and then
they had had a transgender person
engraved onto the person's headstone and
then this person would be a social
justice warrior hero but the Sun
happened like Alf and that means this is
a terrible terrible mega grandmother
terrible terrible person yeah the
terrible person it seems to me is the
person who's ripping on a person whose
kid died at the age of 24 whatever you
choose to put on your kids headstone at
the age of 24 I really don't think it's
anybody else's business frankly okay
other things that I hate so there's this
article it's just astonishing remember
when what you did in the bedroom was
your business remember that that was
like five minutes ago we were told that
the LGBT movement should that their
basic goal was to have Americans not
care about what they did in the bedroom
and I was like okay fine I'm with you
cool enjoy whatever free country now it
turns out that the left once you dictate
who you should want to have sex with
there's an article and a website called
them at us okay they think it's a it's a
gay friendly website or a gay advocacy
website and here's what it rights
considering the discrimination trans
people face on a daily basis it comes as
no surprise that trans people are
overlooked when it comes to dating to
Canadian researchers recently asked
almost a thousand cisgender folks that's
people whose sex matches their gender
right in other words you're man who
thinks you're a man if they would date a
trans person in a new study published in
the Journal of Social and personal
relationships is the first ever study to
attempt to quantify the extent of trans
discrimination when it comes to romantic
and sexual relationships ok let me just
point something out I thought that it
was my prerogative as a free human being
to decide with whom I would like to have
sex I thought that either wait right
here there was a biological drive right
if you're gay then you are biologically
gay and you don't think get to decide
who you're attracted to that's just the
way it works or you get to choose whom
you have sex with because it's a free
country the left has now decided that it
is both a biological drive but if you
don't want to have sex with the people
they want you to have sex with it's
because you're discriminating right this
is where the the two definitions of the
word discrimination cross over and
things get real weird
so discrimination can be me
discriminating between two types of
drink that I want to drink or two types
of people one of whom I want to have sex
with him one of whom I don't I'm a
straight man that means I like having
sex with my wife right I like having sex
with women that is a discriminatory
attitude because I'm discriminating
between women and men in making that
particular decision but that's not bad
discrimination bad discrimination is
saying that all members of a particular
group are biologically inferior or I
wouldn't hire a member of a particular
group or something like that okay but
the left has now conflated these two
things any sort of decision in which you
like one thing more than another you
like hamburgers more than you like tacos
right if that is your thing that is now
bad discrimination according to
according to the left 958 participants
all but seven cisgender ranging in age
from 18 to 81 with an average age of 26
we're asked to indicate which genders
they would consider dating the options
included cisgender man cisgender woman
trans man trans woman or genderqueer and
participants could select as many
genders as they wanted only 12
participants only 12% of all
participants selected trans woman and/or
trans man right because it turns out
that most people would like to date a
member of the sex to which they are
attracted why is this even remotely
controversial those who would consider
dating a trans person didn't differ in
race or ethnicity but were somewhat
older more likely to hold a university
degree and unsurprisingly less likely to
be religious than those who would not
date a trans person
but some of the most striking
differences were in regards to
participants gender and sexual
orientation this is my favorite part
okay this is best part of the study
virtually all heterosexuals excluded
trans folks from their dating pool only
1.8 percent of straight women and 3.3
percent of straight men chose a trans
person to be their binary gender why is
this shocking if I'm a straight man I
don't want to have sex or be dating a
biological man or a woman who believes
she is a man why is this remotely
controversial in any way this is
ridiculous okay if you're a straight
woman I assume that you don't want to
date a person with a vagina or date a
person with the or date a person with a
vagina who a person with a penis who
believes that he is a woman like what
okay and then but this is the best part
most non heterosexuals weren't down for
dating a trans person either oh no it
turns out that a lot of LGBTQ people
only want to take people of the sex to
which they are attracted oh no only
11.5% of gay men and 29% of lesbians
being trans inclusive in their dating
preferences bisexual queer non-binary
participants were most open to having a
trans partner but even among them almost
half did not select either trans man or
trans woman because it turns out you're
attracted to certain types of people and
those people typically have to have the
set of genitals that you prefer and also
believe that they are a member of the
sex that has that particular set of
genitals why in the butt it's all
controversial you understand any
discrimination is controversial any
decision you make is controversial
all of this demonstrates the full scale
stupidity of the left I hope that they
continue along this path because I
promise you human biology will not stand
for this sort of political nonsense okay
we will be back here tomorrow with all
of the latest updates i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah al Vera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018